I'm Renee Taylor I'm in the pilot rock
and a hard place and the rock star is
Patrick Muldoon and I'm playing his
mother this is a spec pilot correct so
it hasn't been picked up I'm just doing
this on spec okay and in terms of your
relationship with the gentleman who's
the rock star what's the background of
that it's complicated it sounds like
he's my son who I love a lot he's been
in and out of rehab his whole life he
has a problem drugs he's estranged from
his ex five children mother
his mother is the most forgiving the
most hurt the most angry so the scenes
start up where he's reunited with you
and you haven't seen each other in
several years right okay how much
background research or backstory are you
creating personally on the mother
character or maybe maybe it's just just
life justjust knowing how that would be
if you'd been estranged from someone and
going from that point if I don't see my
son for a day I feel strange
I feel abandoned so I can imagine what
it would be like her few years are you
working off a script or is a lot of this
improv no we're working off a script I'd
say
80% script 20% improvise when you work
with a director when they do you enjoy
the freedom of improving or do you like
the structure of health I like the
freedom of improv but I think the art is
really in improvising in the structure
to make it spontaneous and appear as it
is improvised even when you during the
lines when you're presented with a
script what's the first thing you start
doing with it you're looking at of
course your part but are you reading the
entire thing from start to finish no I
just really start with my part and see
whether I have empathy or my part
compassion and think it's funny we hear
a lot of actors say that they don't like
to judge their character I find that
interesting that you you have to have
empathy if you don't have empathy for
the part that you may play do not take
the role or do you feel that you can
still work with it I can work with it
because everybody's innocent even Lady
Macbeth if anything so with this
character the mother you felt empathy
toward her what were some of the things
that you identified with that made you
like her her pain her rage
Afiya a joy have fun
everything she's very multifaceted and I
like that about characters I like that
about people like when they're many
times too many people right oh we're all
complicated in many ways are there
scenes where there's some fights where
it becomes very emotion oh yeah
Barrie and how is that for you when they
cut and you've had to raise your voice
or get mad do you need a moment
now would you want to keep going I don't
need anything I can go I can cry I can
laugh I can get angry I am like a sieve
it just goes in and out of me and it's
all fun I like feelings I like to have a
lot of feelings I love to cry I'd love
to get angry I love to be scared I love
to do all the feelings joy I'm trying to
think if there's any feeling that I
don't like playing the hardest feeling
to play is no feeling to be repressed to
be dumb to be boring is the hardest
thing to play is that because you feel
emotions so right now because there's a
lot of feeling that goes into no feeling
there's a lot of feeling that goes into
repression a lot of feelings
so if you've had to play that character
before it doesn't sound like with this
mother character that that's what you're
playing but how do you go there then how
do you become so banal or flat well you
have all the feelings but you don't show
them you don't express them they were
all there and you rise above them or you
don't show them actually it's a very
interesting thing to play now you are
from New York City is that right or the
Newark area and I'm sorry when did you
come to the Los Angeles area about 40
years ago 40 years ago okay do you
remember that day that you took the trip
to come to LA and what was that like I
was here to do a Jerry Lewis movie and
that was very exciting and you'd already
gotten the word that you would be coming
to LA and yes he said to me if you're
ever in California look me up so I flew
there and I said okay I'm here so when
you were flying you know 3,000 miles
away
what was going through your mind on that
plane oh I'm gonna see him he's gonna be
so excited he's gonna put me in his
movie there was no there was no fear no
doubt when you're young you just are
fearless
that's how I was I was fearless I had a
lot of courage and I thought the world
was waiting for me
and so looking back on it was there
anything you would have changed from
from your from your journey from New
York to LA where you did everything you
feel that it was sort of meant to be
I think I would have been more grateful
that's all
I'm all grateful good thing the good
fortune that happened to me I would just
be more grateful about it well I know
for many people that come to LA you're
younger and the world treats you
differently when you're younger and and
sometimes they're more embracing and so
I get where people get that uber
confidence or they think that nothing
bad can ever happen and and it's all
going to be this way forever yes but at
some point when do you turn it into the
love for the craft when you've gotten
beyond all the accolades and it's more
about just wanting to do it because you
need to do it what when did that happen
when it's what you need to do very
shortly after I began I went to Lee
Strasberg class and I just fell in love
with the craft and I went there every
day and sat there all day
I never went home and finally he's the
one who told me I after about six years
I think you ought to get a job now
because I was just sitting there wanting
to learn everything I didn't really want
to go and do it except in class so he
was either sort of like well I should
clean up the term but get off the pot
basically is kind of you know he wasn't
even saying you're ready okay good I was
saying oh I'm not ready I don't know
about this I don't know about the
classics and he said no you're good
enough just go get a job and the first
job that I got in the theater was to be
in the little the little Natasha in the
three sisters the Chekhov play and he
recommended me actually for that far
so going back to the time that you were
just there sitting what was it that was
stopping you he sounds like you felt
like you were in your element
just watching being in class it was just
so awesome the process was so awesome
there was so much to know he was so
passionate I was so passionate I just
was like a sponge and was just and it
was safe you know you didn't have to go
in for juice you just could learn you
could just grow it was like time out to
be a student it was great to be a
student so lastly any advice for someone
that's come far from home maybe they
have family waiting for them who wants
them to come back but they've come to
this city but they are kind of in limbo
because they do have talent but they
feel safe whether it's in a classroom
setting and any tough way you know then
you have to just take the risk that
someone is going to say you don't get
out and don't ever come back and you'd
have to say well I've been thrown out of
better places than this I've been turned
down from better things than this and
just go on